first up my delicious pan-fried pork
chops with sweet and sour peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
pan on
get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet sound peppers go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up trying
to slice a pepper
on the side is a nightmare there's the
center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look that's what you want
now place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind
pinky holding it down thumb holding nice
and flat the flatter the vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
and take your time
speed comes the most important thing
is to get your technique right
red onion
now sweet sour peppers
olive oil in
[Music]
i'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's turn for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt
and pepper
add a tablespoon of sugar sugar helps to
break down the peppers quicker but
caramelize the onions frying them in a
frying pan perfect it's one of the sort
of basic essential tools of any kitchen
because it's so multi-purpose great for
sauteing
tossing
great for cooking fresh and meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak in
you now start to see it glistening the
way that it's starting to caramelize
sugar's working beautifully
that's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you can see the sugar
it's worked as magic
turn down the gas and add a couple of
tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now i want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic just
roll the basil
almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in and then literally cook it out
for 30 seconds
i want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now for the pork chops
i want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
curling up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the rind means
the chop stays flat and cooks evenly
point the knife down
flip through this seasoned beautifully
nice large
shards of pepper punch that through
lightly guaranteed that seasoning
is gonna stay there
hot pan touch garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic
take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in
just starting to smoke
top of the chop
in
and lay away from me
nice
keep that heat in the pan
put the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork is staying nice and
flat
turn that over look at that beautiful
i want a little bit of thyme underneath
there
start squeezing that garlic out i want
the flavor coming out
butter in
thin slices of butter
tilt the pan and baste
so i'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time i'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color of that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side useful
when they're that thick
three and a half to four minutes each
side
thirty seconds from now they're gonna be
medium so i'm gonna take them out and
let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
[Music]
a nice spoon
of these peppers the basil smells
incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your confidence is gonna shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour peppers
my next recipe turns what used to be a
decidedly unfashionable cut of meat into
the star of the dish fit to grace any
table
slow roasted pork belly with fennel
[Music]
slow roasting works better on fattier
tougher and unfashionable cuts whether
it's a cheek or even a neck or this
amazing pork belly it's a fantastic way
to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection
take a very sharp knife
bring the pork belly towards you so
you're over it and you've got all that
pressure and weight using the tip of the
knife i'm just sort of
nicking it and go across the pork belly
long strokes with a knife take your time
turn it
180.
this time what we're doing is just sort
of cutting those nice little sort of
diamonds but as that starts roasting on
top it starts getting nice and crispy
take
little handfuls of salt and just sort of
rub it in
bend it over and in all those cracks
really helps to get a nice crisp
crackling on top
roasting tray
getting really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
i'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables crush and
peel three whole cloves of garlic and
add to the fennel olive oil in
fennel in
i like the
nice strong
anita flavour
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds
delicious
star anise
in
and just
a couple of cardamom seeds and wow
they're like little bangers like little
firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just sear
the top of that fat that locks in all
that amazing flavor then i'm gonna flip
it over and get it nice and crispy
and then one fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now
some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that pan
you can smell that light
fragrance from the fennel
allow the wine to bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol has burnt off time
that the stock now the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there will be
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes
crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and brazes at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never get
up to temperature
smells incredible
slow roast the pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that
you've got that nice crispy skin on top
you can see how much of the stock
has evaporated
put that onto the board
it looks stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavour-packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat
take a couple of slices of bread it's
like a perfect sponge because you just
lay that
on top
and drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that
fat if you want the perfect fried bread
trust me stick that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard
whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
with your pork belly
always use a nice serrated edge knife
you can hear that
oh
that
is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is gonna almost melt
in your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy
belly of pork
what an amazing way to cook a very cheap
cut of meat
[Music]
smoky pork sliders with barbecue sauce
everyone loves a burger they're a true
fast food original and that's the
exciting thing about street food you can
take an old classic like that and
reinvent it into something really
exciting
when you think of a burger what you need
is a great sauce and unlike smoky
barbecue goes hand in glove with a great
burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
nice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
a nice seasoning salt and pepper
now the secret of a good barbecue sauce
is that really important caramelization
to begin with a nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
it darkens the onions but it really
starts to sort of give that nice syrupy
body to the sauce
and put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you've got to cook them out
and almost sort of burn off that rawness
especially with a smoked paprika that's
exactly where i want it to go
onions and garlic beautifully
caramelized
cider vinegar in
reduce that down now i've got a
fantastic smoky base to complete the
sauce i'm making my life really easy and
adding pre-made worcester sauce and
tomato ketchup cook that out for two to
three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce that determines how long
you cook it out for i don't want it to
be too
runny but i don't want it too thick
either
that's the consistency we're looking for
lovely
turn down the gas
charger seasoning
now
take that out
it's the kind of sauce that i like to
have sort of bottled up in the fridge
it's great for sandwiches
but goes brilliantly well with these
sliders
homemade smoky barbecue sauce
[Music]
give the pan a little wipe
now start the mix for the sliders to
give my mix a really interesting flavor
and texture i'm gonna be using unsmoked
back bacon i
travel
all over the world
and i spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders beef sliders chicken
sliders and it's almost like a way of
having a burger
but on a much smaller miniature level
little teaspoon of olive oil
i want that bacon to get really nice and
crispy
bacon in
this just gives the really nice sort of
chunky delicious mix i want texture
and pork is perfect for a slider
[Music]
and choppy slot
slots are a lot sweeter than your normal
white onion
fine fine fine and in
[Music]
now that bacon's getting really nice and
crispy i want a bit of heat in there a
little teaspoon
of smoked paprika in there
when you see these sliders in the states
for one portion there's like four or
five of them little mini one biters
incredible
now take your pork
just open up
and give that a really nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so
season it nicely
bake
now that's nice and crispy
just take a little touch
kitchen roll and just drain that off
there nice
pat that
nice and dry i want all that nice sort
of crispiness
in there
beautiful mix all that
in
take
a nice ball and sort of
roll it
the size of a golf ball
get it nice and round first and then
three fingers
just pat that down
don't flatten them too thin otherwise
they overcook and they go
sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot
a tablespoon of olive oil
when a slider is literally that thick
about an inch thick
we're going to take two and a half to
three minutes to each side
in
turn them over
lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them
keep my mouth watering now
it's very easy to dry the pork out so
just feeling it now with your fingers is
nice and firm
it's a little touch of springiness in
the center i'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted
i'm using wedgies of smoked cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess to the slider
finally shredded baby gem lettuce
just take those buns
make sure they're sliced
nice and evenly
take your lettuce be quite generous with
the lettuce
just a nice thin slice
of tomato
take your burgers
you see that cheese
you feel melted your bbq sauce
place the top on
and that is my version of a slider that
is small dynamic but packed full of
flavor i'll take that over a hamburger
any day
sticky pork ribs
one of the secrets to great cooking is
patience leaving dishes to marinade for
one or two days helps to develop the
flavor in your food and the end result
so much more delicious it's a method i
use in the restaurants all the time
first off get your roasting tray put the
tray on the gas
pork ribs 60 meat and 35 40 fat give
them a really good season salt
and pepper
nice thing about this cut they stay
incredibly moist when they're on the
bone and the longer you cook them the
more delicious they become and just push
all that seasoning in to the pork olive
oil in
make sure that tray is nice and hot
and i really want that nice sort of
caramelization taking place on the pork
that's the nice thing about starting it
on top of the stove use your roasting
tray get them colored and then the oven
putting the ribs straight in the oven
you don't get the color
it looks sort of boiled as opposed to a
nice caramelized rib
ginger
you can't beat fresh ginger with sticky
pork ribs
place it down nice and firmly and slice
the thinner you slice the ginger
the more fragrant the ribs
garlic
now it's really important before you add
anything
to those ribs make sure you've got the
color from the ribs first don't rush it
turn them over that's what i want
that nice crispy color
as they sort of
braise in the oven all that color just
turns into the most amazing flavor
braising is just a chef's term for
cooking something slowly in liquid
right ginger and garlic in spread it
around on all those ribs to sort of
roast the ginger and the garlic chili
flakes
chili flakes in next szechuan pepper
citrusy vibrant peppercorns incredible
in
next star anise that gives it a really
nice sort of anisd flavor almost like
you're roasting the ribs in fennel and
now we've got the heat
got the spice
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
some fresh honey
honey glazes the pork beautifully
counteracts against all that spice in
there
but look what's happening a color on the
ribs is extraordinary
it's like a really nice chili sweet
caramel now
soy sauce brings that little bit of
saltiness to it
really generous with the soy sauce
japanese vinegar
two tablespoons of vinegar in
rice wine
it gives it that nice sort of um
tartness the ribs
if you can't find rice wine our dry
sherry's a great substitute
300 ml
that takes out the heat of that szechuan
pepper those dry chili flakes make sure
they're all laid down like a nice tight
box of matches bring that up to the boil
cooking is all about learning to develop
your own likes and dislikes so always
keep tasting to make sure you're happy
with a combination of flavors
it's lacking a little touch of vinegar
what that sharpness
now think what's going on the tartness
the heat the caramel the color on the
ribs is amazing i want a bit of a sort
of oniony flavor put some springiness in
whilst these ribs are in the oven the
spring onions will sort of puree they
give a sharpness
the final taste of that pork
in with my spring onions
and with my stock
400 ml of stock
this is just a
simple chicken stock
the stock just sits underneath the ribs
it absorbs into the rib and the top of
the rib glazes
underneath the rib that gets crispy and
rich and that's what makes the ribs nice
and moist really important into the oven
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
[Music]
now
wow
they smell incredible
each side has got that really nice
crispy roasted egg becomes sticky and
chewy and sweet sour the fats
disappeared and the pork just melts in
your mouth i want to take them to the
next level gas back on now
shake the tray and this is the sort of
the way that we finish them in the
restaurant
but every minute
they glaze
in that tray they just get to taste
better and better
now look at them
i'm so happy with those
ribs done
absolutely delicious now but if you want
you can put them in the fridge and the
flavor will keep developing then just
reheat them when you want to
so
[Music]
each rib has a nice slice of ginger on
there
[Music]
wow look at that
delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade